make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and uh
have you guys seen
the previews for future state superman
worlds of war
it looks amazing right it's written by
becky cloonan uh it basically looks like
superman like planet hulk with superman
but it looks
cool like i'm super excited to check it
out matt is happy to think about that uh
so we are
covering the origin of clown hunter
which is something that a lot of you
guys have asked for and it's actually
very fortuitous we waited until now
because i didn't realize dc was going to
be releasing a one-shot origin of clown
hunter which i would have known had i
just looked it up
but uh it's cool right we've got this
now this is the full-on origin of his
character because in a lot of ways
we didn't really know what all went into
his character development we simply just
knew that he became clown hunter because
his parents were killed
during or at least at some point by the
joker right so this gives us the full-on
origin which i'm excited to cover so
here's the thing this initially
opens up really with leslie tompkins and
crime alley right now leslie tomkins
those of you guys who don't know
she's kind of like the night nurse of dc
comics right she's been around for a
really really long time
but she's the one who kind of runs this
free clinic down in crime alley
in order to serve those individuals who
are underprivileged right whether
they're
uh vigilantes or sometimes even
criminals or people who can't afford to
go to like a hospital because they don't
have health insurance or something like
that
she basically tends to their to their
their injuries and their wounds and and
so on uh and so because of that she's
very much
a respected member of the community and
this really because
it really kind of reflected when you
have this guy who shows up out of
nowhere
looking to rob her right like to
literally like rob a woman who runs a
free clinic in crime alley right now
this guy big eddie kind of shows up and
he's like look like this is leslie
tompkins that you're robbing so like i'm
gonna break you apart piece by piece if
you don't get out of here
you know you guy the robber ultimately
leaves right but the important thing
behind this is that once leslie gets to
her clinic
she's met by the arrival of clown hunter
right by by i think it's how you
pronounce his name but the whole point
behind this and the reason why this
matters is because
he comes in there really kind of having
his injuries tended to after he
uh after he left right in the the last
batman story arc that we covered where
he almost killed harley and that's kind
of what he says right she's like you
know why why are you here now but like
why come to this place now
and the reality is he's experiencing an
existential crisis and the reason for
that is we jump back to three years
prior
and you've got him just kind of in his
bedroom playing video games his mom kind
of gets pissed and says look uh either
you could have helped me downstairs
right or you can help me around the
house and her old stance is like i gave
you a choice right either you could
clean up your room or you could help
your father downstairs get ready for the
dinner rush right he's like there were
only two people in the restaurant
yesterday what kind of a dinner rush is
there really but you know ultimately his
mom's just you know his mom does what
moms do
you know which is like i will i brought
you into this world and i will take you
out
so ultimately of course he ends up going
downstairs and helping his dad
enter harley quinn and harley quinn of
course shows up with her two hyenas now
given the the way she's dressed and so
on you know this is you know
relatively soon to when she ended up
leaving joker or at least sometime
around relatively soon one thing to keep
in mind when it comes to comics they
don't usually keep uh keep track of real
world events like a real world time
and so while it's technically three
years ago uh this could have been
you know 20 years ago or or 10 years ago
in comic book time right so it's one of
those weird kind of funky things where
it's like
it's just at some point along the line
with harley quinn right uh but when she
shows up here she's kind of like so mr
mr j the joker like
we literally just got done knocking over
a whole bunch of jewelry stores in the
diamond district and we're hungry so i
told him that you know i
used to have foam all the time when i
was younger when i was in uh in college
and so he wants to come here and try
some right so
you know the joker comes walking in he's
like we'll take a table for two and
immediately
immediately clown hunter's parents are
like oh crap and like he you know clown
hunter like bao goes to reach for a
knife
now it's kind of one of these funny
things because his dad steps in that
says no we don't escalate things right
this is the joker we're talking about
now this is the kind of fear that the
joker has on the city of gotham not
because of the fact that he's so
incredibly violent that is part of the
fear factor but because of the fact that
he's so unpredictable
you don't know if he's going to just
kind of leave like if the joker would
just leave here and then go back and do
his thing or if the joker would massacre
everybody in this place right there's no
way of knowing what the joker's going to
do because the joker's schemes don't
make sense to anybody but himself and so
because of that
you end up having bao who's basically
told to kind of back off and then of
course joker and harley quinn are eating
their meal and and that kind of a thing
and so harley's like you know what we
should get out of here we should go find
we should go fence these things you know
that kind of stuff and then joker's like
that sounds good right like go grab the
car
and and take the kids but where harley
quinn ends up leaving the joker still
stays behind
and this is a very daunting situation
because now it's one of these things
where it's almost kind of like okay
now it's just the two of us you know and
and it's it's a little creepy
right because this is usually where the
joker ends up just kind of being insane
and so ultimately he's told by the
father of bow look the meal's on the
house man
right like we really were really glad
that you enjoyed it and uh and make sure
you get home safely and and the joker's
like okay like you know i really need to
give you guys a big tip so here's a tip
that i'm giving you
don't breathe and like sprays them down
with the with the joker talk so now i'm
gonna be honest with you guys i kind of
laughed
when i was originally when i was
initially reading this i was like i mean
i know it's not
funny but it's it's kind it was kind of
funny a little bit and i was like man
this is this is messed up but ultimately
of course it ends up exposing bao and
his and his and
you know about his mother and father to
the toxin and that's how they're killed
now this is why he associates harley
quinn with that
because harley quinn was part of the duo
of the joker right she was part of the
one-two punch that where harley quinn
went the joker went right it's just kind
of the nature of these things and so
because of that you know harley quinn is
every bit as as complicit in the joker
in this because harley quinn
knew what the joker was going to do
right well she knew there was a high
likelihood that he would kill them that
the joker's insanity uh would
lead him to do something bonkers right
so she's just as guilty as the joker is
right because she just kind of
enabled it and allowed it to happen now
when their bodies are being carried out
this is when commissioner gordon kind of
steps up and says there's somebody who
wants to talk to you and that's when val
comes face to face with batman for the
very first time
and as the two of them are talking
there's a lot of anger inside bauer he
just lost his parents
there's a lot of anger a lot of a lot of
emotion and a lot of desire for
vengeance and he asked batman to make a
promise right batman gives him a
batarang
and battle says make a promise promise
me you're going to do something about
this right now as we know with batman he
never really does anything about the
joker right so this is really a promise
that batman
had no intention of keeping and so
because of that it basically leads to us
kind of jumping back
to this moment right now where you have
leslie talking directly with with bao
himself and it's one of these things
where
it's it's a really interesting
conversation here because he kind of
asks her you know like why
why did you why are you helping me out
here right i could be some kind of
creepy weirdo killer she's like i know
that's what you are right
i know you're the clown hunter i've
heard of the clown hunter of the neros
you know i know you're one going around
and killing everybody who wore a clown
mask during the joker war who committed
all these heinous acts i know you're the
person who's doing that the question i
have is
why did you come to me and the funny
thing is again he's having a bit of an
existential crisis that he found harley
quinn that he got a hold of harley quinn
he had the opportunity to kill harley
quinn and he didn't and so now he
doesn't know what he's supposed to do
right if his sole purpose for
the last you know however long was to
basically track down and kill clowns
everywhere he found them and then then
he let one go
now he's made an exception to the rule
and because he lived his life
but you know being defined by this rule
or at least lived you know a portion of
his life
being defined by this rule when you make
an exception to the rule you live by
then of what value is the rule that you
follow and that's the
that's the the situation that he's in
here that's what he's trying to figure
out because
now he's in that situation where it
comes to the line drawing right that's
the problem with making exceptions to
the rules is where do you draw the line
suddenly it shifts and changes all the
time
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
depending on what rule we're talking
about
it's reasonable to have a hard and fast
line on like killing people right
but like you know running a yellow light
no cops really gonna pull you over for
that right running a red light yeah but
like or going like 10 miles over the
speed limit on the interstate right
there's these kind of hard and fast
rules right
officially the speed limit 75
unofficially it's like 85 or 90 possibly
if there's not really a cop that you
know not not really happy around you
sometimes even 100 or 110 or 115 you
know if you're hanging out with benny
and driving his dodge challenger which
is really cool you know it depends on
the situation right it depends on what's
going on
you know it depends on the rules but
nonetheless you know it's one of these
things
where where in his mind he almost kind
of defines his existence
in terms of video game logic right now
before all the gamers start coming out
and girls
here people are saying video games are
violent that's not what that's not what
they're saying here right and you know
better than that
the the point that he's making here is
that in video games there is a direct
reward system for what you do right
video games are predicated on some kind
of a point-based system maybe not so far
as a direct point-based system but like
a point-based system nonetheless right
xp leveling up different things like
that and so because of that you commit
an act you're rewarded for that act
right now your reward may be something
that you don't like
you you may be rewarded with a
punishment but you're rewarded
nonetheless
right and so because of the fact because
of that he's kind of lived under the
purview of his parents
right do what i tell you to do and you
will get a positive reward uh
do you know do what i told you not to do
and you'll get a bad reward you take
that
you combine it with the reward based
system of video games and all he's
really known his whole life is that
if you do good things good things happen
to you if you do bad things bad things
happen to you and the reality is
the world doesn't work that way that
good things happen to bad people
that bad things happen to good people
and everywhere in between right
a person who's done nothing but but act
like a dick to people his entire life
wins the lottery and a person who's been
the nicest guy in the world
just always ends up coming up last right
sometimes that's just the way that it
works right
not everybody gets their just desserts
and walking around the world with the
philosophy of
everything good happens to good people
everything bad happens to bad people is
a recipe for disaster
in this situation something terrible
happened to bao's parents and they never
did anything bad
it flew in the face of everything he
knew and what he desires
is for sanity to return to the world
because his world has completely gone
topsy-turvy it's turned
upside down now this became evident in
the fact that as you know
in the aftermath of meeting with batman
that he constantly recollected this
promise that batman made to him
i promise you i will i will stop this i
promise you i will do something about
the joker but every single time he
turned on the tv or he saw the news or
whatever it was and there was another
escape by joker from arkham asylum and
joker going on another killing spree and
killing more people and batman putting
joker back in arkham asylum and then
joker escaping again you know like well
it was it was it was one of these things
where it was constantly a case of batman
just
never really doing anything to stop the
joker then he started to lose
faith right he started to start to to
lose belief in the fact that joker would
actually do the right thing and so it's
one of these really really cool
discussions
that that kind of takes place between
leslie and val
where he brings up this this statement
he says there are things out there in
the world
that need to be done in life and that's
what i don't get there's so much out
there
that so obviously needs to get done but
nobody's doing anything
if i don't do this who's going to stop
them all the people who took off their
masks and went back to their lives and
the response of leslie is
why do they need to be stopped maybe
they had a change of heart notice the
two completely differing
opinions here leslie is of an opinion
well everybody should be forgiven for
the things that they've done maybe they
changed their mind maybe they realized
that they made a mistake maybe they were
somebody who was in a rough situation
and it was their their only real outlet
whatever it is it is an entire
philosophy based on excusing people of
their actions but
the the stance of vow is no we don't
excuse them for what they did they did a
terrible thing
they need to pay the price for what
they've done that any possibility of
receiving redemption
went out the window when they committed
such heinous acts and this wasn't a
situation of people who were going
through
and just like robbing banks or anything
like that in his mind when he goes
through and he specifically targets
these clowns it's because of the things
that they did that he kind of tells
leslie
he tells leslie that the breaking straw
for him was during the joker war himself
that when he was going through when he
was when he was in his place and the
whole thing started to pop off
and all these criminals started donning
clown masks and rallying themselves
under the ideology of the joker that
they were doing things like burning
people alive
they were beating beating people to
death right they were
satisfying every despicable desire they
had
in their in their minds and their bodies
and in that at that point in time
the way that thou sought they were
broken and they were beyond any real
hope for redemption that any chance they
had of of being able to say hey look
you know i'm sorry for my actions that i
want to repent that's gone right that's
that's basically gone right you know
it's one of these things what is it
geneva conventions the the nuremberg
trials
saying i was just following orders is
not good enough anymore and that's what
makes clown hunters so interesting
because clown hunter is kind of the
answer to the question what happens when
a person
doesn't believe the lies of batman
anymore when batman says
i promise i'll do something about the
joker right what happens when somebody
wakes up and says
every time batman says this nothing ever
gets done ergo
batman can't be trusted to keep his
promise in dealing with the joker
right what happens when somebody gets to
that point the point that you get
is clown hunter because what ends up
happening is there's a woman by the name
of mrs nugent who was set on fire by by
one of these guys in clown mask and in
that moment
he snaps right he has this recollection
back to his statement that his mom had
made to him your father needs help i
need help don't lose yourself in a fake
world
we need you here in the real world doing
real things
and that's when he kind of starts to
realize the fake world is the world
where batman will save us the fake world
is the world where we have to rely on
batman to make gotham a better place
because the reality is if batman was
going to make gotham a better place he
would have but he hasn't and therefore
batman cannot be believed or trusted and
so it's one of these things where he
basically says fine
if batman's going to be a half measure
then i will be a full measure
and that's when he basically ends up
taking the batarang he puts it into the
bat he basically makes it he literally
uses the bottom of a
of a broom and just like attaches you
know all the little straws to his hat he
paints it and he goes forward as clown
hunter
grabs you know takes the baseball bat
beats the crap out of one of the one of
the clowns and then sets him on fire
and it's just kind of like you know this
is this is the end right where a whole
bunch of other clowns come after him he
in turn
kills all of them as well and notice
something he did something here
that batman has never been able to do
throughout the entirety of gotham city
clown hunter
made these guys afraid to come to his
neighborhood people are not afraid of
committing crimes in gotham because
they're not afraid of batman we know
that because people commit crimes in
gotham
but in terms of of what's going on in in
crime alley or at least in the narrows
a clown hunter all these guys afraid to
come to his neighborhood they never came
back
once once he went on that war path and
killed every clown he found they
wouldn't come back and the reason why is
because
unlike batman where all the the most
they have to be worried about
is handed over to the justice system
which is probably ill-equipped to handle
them and then they're thrown in jail
then like they escape or something like
that
with with clown hunter they have to
worry about living that he introduced a
level of consequence that they simply
just
weren't willing to accept and that's the
nature of things that's the huge thing
that's the big difference here that was
somebody like leslie tompkins she's
avidly against the idea of using
violence right she says violence never
solves anything that's not true
violence solves lots of things right
violence is not always the answer but it
is a
answer and it's a very effective answer
problem with violence is it makes people
uncomfortable and it disrupts the status
quo
it kind of flies in the face of the
comfortable life they live
and it asks them to make sacrifices that
they're just not willing to make right
so people want things to change
they just don't want to have to do
anything that actually requires change
but but clown hunter stepped in and said
no things need to change
if people aren't willing to do what
needs to be done to at least make my
neighborhood safer then the hell with it
i'll do it on my own and that's exactly
how he became the character that he
became right
that's one of the interesting things
here is because violence again it
introduces a kind of it does create more
violence
that's true but sometimes that's just
the price you pay and ultimately you
kind of have to end up becoming that
kind of a person
that you have to become a kind of person
where you look at a circumstance and say
okay i'm facing off against a situation
where the people involved
just cannot be fixed they cannot be
redeemed there's no way to save them
they're just too far gone and no matter
what i do or what i try or how hard i
work there's no way to bring them back
and so the only way to make the world
better
is to get rid of them it's the only way
and it's not one of these these lines of
logic that you use as a one-off right
like that guy robbed a bank
kill him that's not what you do right
it's one of these things where it's like
okay why is this guy robbing a bank is
this guy robbing a bank because he's in
a really really bad situation if he is
then how do we find a way to resolve
that situation right is he down in his
luck is he out of a job is there
something i can do to help him get back
on his feet to get a job there's all
kinds of situations out there
where you can use non-violence as a
means to improve people's lives but the
ability to use non-violence to approve a
person
to improve a person's life stops once
they demonstrate incorrigibility the
inability and the refusal to stop doing
what they're doing
and to keep becoming to literally keep
becoming more violent the issue that you
run into when you use that is you kind
of create your standard
in terms of at what point does somebody
come for you right so if clown hunter is
one of these guys where he's like i'm
gonna kill every single clown out there
every single clown that was there doing
the joker work i'm going to kill them
and then once once they're all dead then
what do i do well at that point then
it's like okay like you've served your
mission and that's why if you're going
to use violence as a means to achieve an
end
you have to have a clearly defined plan
for why you're using that violence
and what your end goal is and it cannot
be an open end goal right you can't you
can't be like batman and just like i
want to make sure nobody experiences the
pain that i experienced when i was a
little kid okay that's way too
open-ended what clown hunter has done
here has actually been to create a kind
of defined
purpose for what he's doing right like
all these people who dressed up as
clowns
and attacked the narrows and bent to
their most baseline desires
these are people that i'm going to kill
because it's not as though you know the
whole event of the joker war
turned them into something they were not
the truth is they were always that
person they were always that kind of
person
they were just looking for a reason to
give them an excuse to allow that
version of themselves out and so at that
point all you're doing is just sparing
the world the existence of what is
already a terrible human being and the
the terrible nature of that human being
is not arbitrarily defined by clown
hunter it's defined by the actions
of that human being and so again it's
one of these things where it makes clear
in rational sense and that's why i say
like clown hunter is a full measure
because he has a clearly defined
idea on who he's going to kill and why
he's going to do it what the motivation
is and why they deserve to die
and the reason why is because they're
terrible people who did terrible things
and showed a callous disregard for
everybody else's human for everybody
else's life for the life of innocent
people
and that's that again is a big
difference right that's a huge
difference going after an innocent
person versus a guilty person and that's
why like the world needs more clown
hunters
[Laughter]
i mean crime will never go away 100 but
it can go away by a lot right and it can
go away by quite a bit right because
dead men cannot be repeat offenders but
the the funny thing about this
is that there's this kind of discussion
where clown hunter shows the sonic kind
of resolved this kind of initiative
right this ability
to basically say like you know i have
the wherewithal and the capability to
make gotham a better place to basically
finish the job that batman
never finishes and what's the response
he's given to by leslie tompkins come to
my anger management course right like
yes you have this incredible passion you
have the ability to make gotham better
and yes there are some people out there
who just genuinely need to die but we
don't want you doing that right like
come to my anger management course you
know and it's kind of crazy because he
even goes as far as to ask her would you
let the joker live and she's like
yes i would let the joker live i would
because deep down there there's still
humanity
there's something down there that can be
saved but he can't but the joker cannot
be saved there's no making him better
there's no
getting him to a place where he wakes up
one day and says my god what have i been
doing all this time man
i've just been killing people man i'm
sure glad batman threw me into arkham
if he hadn't done it for the 100th time
i never would have learned my lesson
right it doesn't it's never gonna happen
right
that's never gonna happen so again i
champion the ideology of clown hunter
and i champion the character it kind of
sucks that she's asking to join an anger
management course right like you have
the ability to change gotham city so
we're gonna try to stop you from doing
that
you know it's it's kind of wild but it
is an amazing origin i'll go as far as
to say that i think the origin of clown
hunter is probably one of the best
origins i've read in a long long time
it's absolutely amazing but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
hey you know
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you